- [Voiceover] So we have a
nice, little equation here
that has some rational expressions in it
and like always, pause the video
and see if you can figure out
which x's satisfy this equation.
All right. Let's work through it together.
Now, when I see things at
the denominator like this,
my instinct is to try to not
have denominators like this.
And so what we could do is to
get rid of this x minus one
in the denominator on the left-hand side.
We can multiply both sides of the equation
times x minus one,
x minus one.
We're gonna multiply both
sides by x minus one.
And once again, the
whole point of doing that
is so that we get rid of this x minus one
in the denominator right over here.
And then to get rid of this x plus one
in the denominator over here,
we can multiply both sides of
the equation times x plus one.
So, x plus one.
Multiply both sides times x plus one.
And so what is that going to give us?
Well, on the left-hand
side, that is going to,
x minus one divided by x
minus one is just gonna be one
for the x's where that's defined,
for x not being equal to one.
And so, we're gonna have x plus one
times negative two x plus four.
So let me write that down.
So we have x plus,
I'm gonna need some space,
so let me make sure I don't write too big.
x plus one times negative two x,
negative two x plus four
is going to be equal to.
Now, if we multiply both of these
times three over x plus one,
the x plus one is going to
cancel with the x plus one
and we're gonna be left with
three times x minus one.
So that is going to be
three x minus three,
and then minus,
minus one times both of these.
So one times x minus one times x plus one.
So, minus one times
x minus one times x plus one.
All I did is I multiplied,
took the x minus one times x plus one,
multiplied times each of these terms.
When I multiply it times this first term,
the x plus one and the
x plus one canceled,
so I just have to multiply
three times x minus one.
And then for the second term,
I just multiply times both of these.
And now you might recognize,
if you have something x
plus one times x minus one,
that's going to be x squared minus one.
So I could rewrite all
of this right over here
as being equal to...
as being equal to
x squared minus one,
and once again, that's
because this is the same thing
as x squared minus one.
And since I'm subtracting
an x squared minus one,
actually, let me just, I don't
wanna do too much on one step
so let's go to the next step.
So, I could multiply this out.
So I could multiply x times negative two x
which would give us
negative two x squared.
x times four,
which is going to give us plus four x
and I could multiply one
times negative two x.
I'm gonna subtract two x.
And then one times four,
which is gonna be plus four,
and then that is going to be equal to,
that is going to be equal to,
we have three x minus three
and then we can distribute
this negative sign.
So we can say minus x squared plus one.
And over here, we can
simplify it a little bit.
This is going to be, that
is four x minus two x
is going to be,
I'm gonna try to write over, yep,
four x minus two x, so
that would be two x.
And so this is simplified to, let's see,
well this is, we have a
negative three and a one,
so those two together
are going to be equal to,
subtracting at two.
So we can rewrite everything as,
do the neutral color now,
negative two x squared
plus two x plus four
is equal to negative x squared
plus three x minus two.
Now we can try to get all of this business
onto the right-hand side,
so let's subtract it from both sides.
So we're gonna subtract,
or we'll say we'll add
x squared to both sides,
add x squared,
that gets rid of this
white negative x squared.
We subtract three x from both sides,
subtract three x from both sides,
add two to both sides, add two,
and we will be left with,
we are going to end up with.
See, negative two x squared plus x squared
is negative x squared.
Two x minus three x is negative x.
And then four plus two is six,
is going to be equal to,
well that's going to
cancel that, that, that,
is equal to zero.
I don't like having this
negative on the x squared,
so let's multiply both
sides times negative one.
And so if I do that,
so if I just take the
negative on both sides,
so I just multiply that
times negative one.
Same thing, it's taking
the negative on both sides.
I'm gonna get positive x squared plus x
minus six is equal to zero.
And we're making some good progress here.
So we can factor this.
And actually, let me just
do it right over here
so that we can see the original problem.
So, if I were to factor
this, what two numbers,
their product is negative six,
they're gonna have different signs
since their product is negative.
And they add up to one,
the coefficient on the first degree term.
Well, positive three
and negative two work,
so I can rewrite this as x plus three
times x minus two
is equal to zero.
Did I do that write? Yeah.
Three times negative two is negative six.
Three x minus two x is positive x.
All right. So, I just wrote this
in this quadratic in factored form.
And so the way that you
get this equaling to zero
is if either one of those equals zero.
x plus three equals zero
or x minus two is equal to zero.
Well, this is going to happen
if you subtract three from both sides.
That's gonna happen if x
is equal to negative three
or over here, if you
add two to both sides,
x is equal to two.
So either one of these will satisfy,
but we wanna be careful.
We wanna make sure that
our original equation
isn't going to be undefined
for either one of these.
And negative three does not make
either of the denominators
equal to zero, so that's cool.
And positive two does not make
either of the denominators equal to zero.
So it looks like we're in good shape.
There's two solutions
to that equation.
If one of them made any of the
denominators equal to zero,
then they would have been
extraneous solutions.
It would have been solutions
for some of our intermediate steps,
but not for the actual original equations
with the expressions as they're written.
But this, we can feel good
about because neither of these
make any of these
denominators equal to zero.